what would you say are the ugliest
qualities you've ever met we all people
have different kind of ugly qualities
selfishness selfishness okay so you
think selfishness is the ugliest one I
think there's uglier than selfish
because I think you're also selfish I
think I'm also selfish I think our kids
are selfish I think pastors are selfish
I think Michael Jordan he was
definitely selfish right and you know it
benefited the people on his team but
there is a definition of selfish right
what else would you say is the ugliest
um
jealousy jealousy what else I don't
disagree
um um hate what else
uh uh uh uh
ugliest quality so selfish jealousy hate
uh what else
um I don't know what they call it let me
rephrase how about unattractive were you
like oh that that energy is just very
unattractive yeah
I really get rubbed the wrong way by
like heavy arrogance like when someone
comes around and talks about themselves
as if they are like bigger than everyone
else
um
and yeah it's negativity okay so I will
say for me unattractive is helpless
very unattractive blame very
unattractive guilt putting guilt on
others very unattractive
what else can I tell you always feeling
sorry self-pity super unattractive I
once read a book called power versus
Force
and I read this book 20 years ago and it
talks about the different levels of
consciousness okay from the lowest to
the highest so level of conscience is
power versus Force I read this book uh
20 years ago and he explains the
different levels from the lowest level
to the highest one so
right in the middle is when life flips
to us actually having power versus we're
forcing it
the lowest level of Consciousness I
think he talks about is apathy or grief
guilt and those are the lowest level and
then there is desire there's anger and
anger is the highest of the worst level
meaning like it's actually better than
grief apathy all of that and then after
anger comes courage
courage is
I have the courage to fail you have the
courage to start a podcast with a
quarter million of subscribers and
somebody comments and says David you
suck I don't like your interview style
well you know what David I can't believe
you had this guest Patrick by David on
why would you do that or why would you
say capitalism works you understand how
hard life is that's a risk you're taking
when you make a video some people come
after you you're not going to get 100
positive comments but you have the
courage to say look at least I'm
creating something right then after
courage comes
neutrality where you're willing to kind
of see both sides maybe off order but
then it goes to acceptance I'm willing
to accept you for who you are it's
totally fine we're different you're
willing to accept me then it becomes
willingness I'm willing to work with you
then reason why don't we reason together
see if we can reason so there's these
levels all the way at the top this
Enlightenment which we're not going to
get to that's Jesus he's talking about
like people who are extreme High AI
spiritual leaders then it's Joy then
it's love then it's happy okay so you're
working with these levels
for somebody that's you're saying your
friend who was you know I've got I don't
care if I ever win a lot I'm still doing
the same job that's what I'm going to be
doing right okay when things change
later on
you know people have to just realize and
identify for themselves what qualities
are ugly
so if if I'm talking victimhood language
always but you don't understand how I
grew up oh my God I can guarantee you
there's millions of stories of people
that had a harder life than you yeah
that would exchange your problems with
you but you know what I've gone through
you don't know what it was like for me
to grow up in La you don't know what it
was like for me to do this you know why
I know that language very well because
that was me until 18 years old so 18. in
the light switch because for me I grew
up in a family where my mother said they
were Communists my dad said we're
imperialists and my mother's side
they're always blamed and they always
were like but no we're never going to be
rich like I remember one time I was 14
years old imperialists
communist can you explain us yes
imperialism is like uh you know like UK
you know where there's a king there's a
queen Iran it was an imperialism and my
mother was more because they escaped
from Russia her family did so they read
Communist Manifesto so they believe rich
people are bad people they believe rich
people are greedy they believe rich
people to take their money and should
give it to other people and all this
other stuff right so I'm this kid
growing up and I'm like oh my God these
rich people suck and I had an uncle his
name was uh Lutheran who just passed
away a couple years ago you know I
always thought this was a bad guy
and I'm like man I'd call him like why
why is this guy such a bad guy and then
every summer night that would take me to
his house once a year he lived right
next to Snoop in Upland off of San
Antonio he had a 7200 square foot square
foot house he always had a blue uh a
Cadillac the real cool Cadillacs and a
Jaguar he was a Jaguar guy basketball
court on the back swimming pool nice
office beautiful kitchen that would
always be there and I would say if he's
such a bad guy why do all his kids love
him
he's such a bad guy why why do his
in-laws love him well why do his
son-in-law married to his dog why do all
these if he's such a bad guy why why is
every time I go on Sunday 50 60 people
there and they're all laughing having a
good time he's cooking for people and it
was successful he was this he was that
so I'm like I don't know Mom I don't
know if I know this and I remember one
time I came home I said Mom are we
Democrats or Republicans I was 14 years
old
and the teachers talking about politics
I said are we Democrats or Republicans
she says we're Democrats it's a CO we're
Democrats I can ask you why we're
Democrats she said because Democrats are
for the poor Republicans are for the
rich
I said to my mom you know what I told my
mom what's that I said Mom when I grow
up I want to be a republican
of course you know what I mean by that
yeah absolutely I have no clue what
Republicans that's what I mean money I'm
just sick and tired of being poor and
having people constantly feel sorry for
me do you know when people bring stuff
for you for Thanksgiving they bring you
once thank you because you're poor they
bring it twice by the third time I don't
want you to feel sorry for me it's an
unattractive quality I don't want you to
look you know the look when somebody
looks at you with the feeling sorry look
I don't like that look I don't think
people should like that look I think
maybe a little bit for a season that
you're going through tough times but if
it's every year now you're feeding into
it now you're believing it now your kids
are starting to believe maybe we are
victims we're not victims
I'm in the Army we're in boot camp and
all of a sudden this mindset of
motivation I'm starting to really feed
myself into it you know 21 22 rounds at
this time I'm 18 19. so I just I went
into the army m18. and I remember one
night we're in the barracks and one of
our guys was he had a hard time because
his girl left him and he wrote him a
letter he broke she broke up over a
letter wife that's tough man it's white
his wife and we're in boot camp his wife
writes a letter to divorce him in a
letter and he can't even call her so
he's in tears he's crying I'm like I
don't even know what to tell this guy
that's painful bro and I go up to myself
I don't know what to tell you here's all
I can tell you this is what I go by if
you and I can walk we can talk you speak
another language you're a good looking
guy you're in shape you take care of
yourself you have jokes you have sense
of humor you can eat you can hear music
you can speak we can do all that stuff
we have all the senses to do something
special with our lives I said it's all
going to be all right it's going to be
painful for a few months but
everything's gonna be all right like
this is what I'm trying to tell this guy
to for him to kind of nothing you say in
a moment like that you guys can um yeah
but he's kind of going through it you
know what I realized eventually I I
bought into that mindset if you can walk
talk speak a language read all the
senses here dude you've got every
capability to change your life so for us
to buy into this well you know but what
if this person doesn't want to do what
if that person doesn't want to do it
you've bought into what you've been
telling yourself and it's now your truth
but it's not the truth and unfortunately
your truth is stealing all your dreams
away from you and until you make a
decision to want to change nothing's
going to change unfortunately your
mindset will most likely duplicate kids
that also follow your mindset until one
person has the courage to stop all that
mindset nothing's going to change for
that family it's not easy to do by the
way change is a very hard thing
foreign